[Musik]
bundesliga süd wieder da er ist fc köln
ist gestern in die erste
fußball-bundesliga aufgestiegen
das ist sehr geil walzen geiler verein
ist allerdings solltet ihr heute nicht
um fußball gehen sondern um freiheit
ich seh schon wieder die ganzen
kommentare von wegen ron luca du bist so
gut den vorteil gibt es auch nur an du
bist so arrogant willst du mit deinen
skizziere scheiße ich weiß wer die profi
vorteil videos sehen wollt könnt ihr
gerne vorbeischauen
bevor wir uns hier jetzt allerdings eine
sohle runde rhein stürzen ganz kurz
nochmal hier oben in den itemshop gehen
unterstützerin creator und hier luca
eingeben und auf annehmen klicken dann
seht ihr schon hier unterstützter
creator lukas kostet das ganze keinen
cent beziehungsweise wibag mehr also
jetzt halt exakt den gleichen preis
allerdings könnt ihr mich damit
kostenlos unterstützen das beim mega
cool allerdings zeige ich jetzt mal
meine skills war gc ist ein charity welt
was macht der denn da für eine scheiße
du fliegen wir hier drüber über die map
meine lieben freundin das heißt sie
gehen natürlich getötet wurden auch
sonst wie bereits mehrfach erwähnt bin
ich nicht der allerbeste fordert spieler
neu genommen bin ich so circa der
schlechteste fordert spieler der welt
ach du heilige scheiße die sie das denn
hieraus alsono steht ich habe halt ein
mega lang keinen vorteil mehr gezockt
weil ich weiss also ist es noch so also
ich schaue mir regelmäßig die videos an
von tiefsee cetera pp und die sache ist
auch was die auch allesamt es denn das
sind teddy am schreibtisch hat was viele
leute ja sagen ist das fordert sondern
ein bisschen ohne waffe zocken irgendwie
immer weniger leute
und keine ahnung also ich weiss nicht
mich wird der eure meinung interessieren
falls ihr selber auch fordert zockt
jetzt noch so wie zu beginn weil er sich
werde ich habe zu beginn auf jeden fall
krass gesagt hat wenn dennoch leider
immer noch ziemlich beschissen
allerdings wird mich eure meinung ja
echt mal interessieren
ich war wie ich kannte mich früher echt
mega gut hier enthielt aus aber jetzt
gerade dass die wahl auch dieser
kirchturm oder wir waren diese l gebäude
oder bin ich gerade komplett besoffen
[Musik]
was ist denn hier los was passiert denn
wenn ich hier vorne in die lava wir sind
aber auf jeden fall in der zone das ist
auf jeden fall schon mal eine freudige
nachricht denn wenn ich im feuer stehen
passiert nichts bis interessant weil ich
eigentlich gerade brenner wir vorne sind
wieder die teil ach du scheiße in ein
super low carb finde ich am mega
interessant was damit passiert ist mit
hilde towers ich kriege wie gesagt ich
bin kein fordert kanal fox nur so das
verfahren ein paar leute feiern wie ich
packe ich war jetzt nicht so sondern
habe mich dann immer den schlaf appell
ist grün das heißt ich dafür auf jeden
fall daran vorbeilaufen
ich würde sagen ich feststellte towers
weil ich hab so gutes lud alter können
besiegen okay vielleicht sollten wir
noch mal zurück kann ich da rein hallo
kann ich ihm sorry an denjenigen der
hier kämpfen heute also ich meine ist ja
echt haben wir hier unter freiem
sternenhimmel hilfeseiten camp
aufzuschlagen
da super bahn sind sogar position kann
ich auch mein gott dessen gene das sind
fliegen jetzt einfach so eine schule
vorstellt jetzt will ich wieder
abgefackelt herrscht muss es einfach
komplett dahin
ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
was ich jetzt hier noch irgendwie groß
machen soll bluten soll
ich dachte war zählte 1000 meter fiel
als lehrer nur noch 37 leute erzählte
tower so mega viel los ich habe keine
ahnung was auch hier ist glaube ich
jemand gestorben
ja
wie geht es euch so schreibt wendy
kommentare gerade echt mega spannend
hier ich dachte hier ist jetzt voll
action irgendwie tötet die stars ananas
aber hier ist halt wirklich weit und
breit kein einziger gegner ich würde
sagen wir laufen hat zum lud lake gold
und gucken ob ich noch schießen kann
also davon ist der luft lag allerdings
ist hier vorne einlud drop an ordnung
gottes typ
[Musik]
aha das war der schlechteste wettkampf
aller zeiten das stimmen auch er guckt
doch zu er ist weg ich höre da hinten
schießen die leute und sehe auch dass da
vorne die party abgeht das heißt aber
hin da geht man von oben dahin wird
meine taschen riss wo sehen sie denn da
ach du scheiße vielleicht doch nicht hin
also da vorne kämpfen die menschen da wo
die sich die ganze zeit abfall an
ich gehe mal direkt in die zone und zwar
auf diesem schiff hier vorne landen war
direkt hier in dem schiffskörper drin
ist hier irgendjemand warum war hier
ganz komischer sound kann ohne steuern
dort kommt er da muss ich mal ganz
schnell wie kann ich denn hier hallo ein
paar sekunden später
na ja eigentlich auch chile könnte ich
mich eigentlich mit der kanone irgendwo
hinstellen junge bin ich zudem die
kanone in diesen raum rein gar das doch
nicht wahrhaben geradeaus hierdurch und
da aber kann ich jetzt hier drin
auch beim sorry ich bin bereit für die
gegner jetzt allerdings gerade schon
mitten in der zone sind und warten
deswegen auch nur noch 13 leute eine
ganz kurze info und zwar wissen ja dass
am 16
in den luca - shop.de neue produkte
launischen werden ich stelle euch heute
eines dieser fünf neuen produkte schon
mal vor und zwar ist es die st
neue web sockets er ist gerade ziemlich
überbelichtet keine ahnung ob man dass
die richtig erkennen kann allerdings ist
das und farbverlauf und der ist so bunt
mit zum regenbogen muster im dass hier
das gummi ist schwarz das hatten wir
erst in weiß geplant allerdings hatten
dann auf instagram die meisten leute
dafür gestimmt dass der schwarz sein
soll so schwarzes gummi bunter pocket
und das hier ist eine der fünf produkte
das am ersten sechs plätzen das erst mal
kurz zu diesem produkt
ich werde definitiv auch in zwei drei
wochen noch mal ein video hochladen wo
ich euch jedes einzelne produkte das am
ersten 69 den shop kommen wird
vorstellen werde
allerdings hatte ich mir gedacht dass
ich jetzt erstmal die nächste zeit euch
in jedem video sonja ein produkt
vorstellen werden also dieses pop rock
ist auf jeden fall eines der fünf neuen
produkte am erster 6 lukas ob es leben
nur noch zehn leute ich bin aber auf
jeden fall immer noch in der zone ich
glaube ich werde mich die ganze folge
heute verstecken
also waren andere möglichkeit habe ich
auch nicht so scheiße wie ich bin ich
sehe es halt wirklich schon wieder in
den kommentaren oder mein gott ich bin
draußen schiedsleute ich sehe es
wirklich schon wieder in den kommentaren
kommen von wegen da drüben scheiße
[Musik]
irgendwo hier
ist ein gegner ich war einfach in meiner
badewanne schmeckt ja der sinn hinter
diesen fordert videos von mir ist
natürlich nicht um euch irgendwie zu
zeigen hey so spielt man das spiel und
guck mal wie gut ich da drin bin und so
weiter und so fort sondern es ist halt
einfach ein spiel was mir persönlich
wirklich sehr viel spaß macht worin ich
aber einfach nicht so gut bin und ich
finde man muss nicht in etwas der
allerbeste sein um darüber videos machen
zu dürfen die zone schickt mich grad ein
bisschen bei gut als geht da ich habe
angst das war direkt bei mir das war
direkt neben mir leute die zone kommt
ich muss mich jetzt ganz langsam mit der
zone bewegen scheiße
nein das ist jetzt nicht wahr das ist
jetzt nicht wahr das kann nicht wahr
sein das ist nicht wahr okay ich habe
ein leben ich habe keine ahnung was die
zone hier gerade veranstaltet aber ich
glaube sie bewegt sich jetzt eben noch
fünf leute was und jetzt lebt nur noch
koks 23 gegen den handy safe geworden
dass ich gestorben bin lag an einer
spitzhacke werde ich jetzt einfach mal
ein itemshop dieses lampen werkzeug hier
kaufen habe ich jetzt natürlich
erfolgreich gekauft mit dem create
support alle luca da nutzen weil das ist
dann ist man cool wie man noch eine
runde und ich mal ein bisschen mehr
action zerstört mal ein paar gegner
olo das geht schon los okay ich war
früher noch irgendwie am handy sonne
wieder zu tötet ausgeben ich fand es ja
irgendwie nicht so nass entscheiden
wofür preisen park also hier werden
jetzt auf jeden fall ein paar leute dem
erdboden gleich gesetzt gemacht meine
ich habe mir direkt megageil waffe ich
glaube dies ziemlich beschissen gucken
wir mal was wir hier so alles ein
bisschen sprengstoff bekommen wir hier
einfach hinschmeißen und dann geschah
ist es ausweg allerdings habe ich ja
gesagt wir machen ein bisschen mehr
action das heißt ich mache jetzt einfach
mal den hier und dann mache ich einfach
mal den hier und dann mache ich den hier
und dann setze ich mich hier mal in das
gestein und dann dahingegen
2000 jahre später will ich weiß dieser
geschützturm ist nur für noobs und so
weiter und so fort aber ich bin halt
movie und steht auch noch mit kürze das
heißt wir schauen mal was mich die
herzlichkeit beschossen ich hätte schon
hilfe lama das aber auch jemand den ich
echt der hat auch was gegen mich jetzt
nur auf mich gegangen
streams laibach propolis sein
beziehungsweise streams nothing ich
hatten auch als sehr sehr viele leute
gefragt weil ich in den letzten monaten
immer meinte dass ich demnächst mal
auftritt streamen möchte nicht
hauptsächlich gaming und fordert sondern
er so lahm anfragen beantworten dies
dass jeder von euch haben mich gefragt
wie es dahingehend aussieht und meine
lieben freunde ich glaube dass in ein
zwei wochen eventuell man erster stream
of which kommen wir jetzt also ich hab
ja schon mal auf twitter stream aber der
erste stream als partner mit geilen
funktion und eine qualität und 2004 hat
er wird auf jeden fall in ein zwei
wochen stattfinden hier findet ein link
zu meinem twitch profil und in der
wieder beschreibung verlinkte dort
findet ihr auch einen link zu meinem
shop wie bereits gesagt am ersten
sechsten kommt dort unter anderem dieses
pop socket in den shop können
allerdings will ich an der stelle das
heutige wird jetzt auch beenden wenn es
euch gefallen hat dass ich mal wieder
fordert gezockt habe dann lass gerne
einen daumen hoch bei diesem video hier
da schreibt nun die kommentare ob ich
noch mal den reporter spielen soll oder
ob ihr er sagt fortnight ist tot ich mag
das spiel nicht mehr so musste nicht
spielen er dürfte entscheidende macht
das spiel auf jeden fall spaß ich bin
wie gesagt echt scheiße aber nicht
meinen kanal falls sie noch kein teil
der news seite und jetzt kommt's drauf
[Musik]